هذا مراسل الجزيره ان طائره تابعه للصليب
الاحمر تقل نحو
125 اسيرا من جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
وصلت الى مطار صنعاء قادمه من مطار عدن
كما وصلت في الوقت نفسه طائره اخرى تقل
خمسه وثلاثين من الاسرى التابعين للحكومه
اليمنيه الى مطار عدن قادمه من مطار صنعاء
وتعد هذه الدفعه الاولى من الاسرى
والمحتجزين التي يجري تبادلها بين جماعه
انصار الله الحوتيين والحكومه اليمنيه ومن
المقرر ان تقلع رحلتان اخريان لنقل عدد
مماثل بعد
ظهر اليوم
بدوره قال الصليب الاحمر الدولي في بيان
ان اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر بدات
بنقل نحو 900 محتجز على صله بالنزاع في
اليمن في اطار عمليه انسانيه تستمر لثلاثه
ايام هذا وافادت اللجنه انها تستخدم
طائراتها لنقل المحتجزين جوا من والى ست
مدن في اليمن والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واضافت اللجنه الدوليه ان عمليه الافراج
تاتي نتيجه المحادثات التي اختتمت في
العشرين من مارس اذار الماضي في مدينه
بارن السويسريه وعربت اللجنه الدوليه عن
املها في ان تعطي مثل هذه العمليات ان
تعطي زخما لحل سياسي اوسع
ونقلت وكاله الانباء اليمنيه عن الفريق
الحكومي المفاوض بملف المحتجزين ان اليوم
الاول من عمليه التبادل يشمل التبادل
محتجزين عبر مطريه اعدن وصنعاء بينهم
اللواء محمود الصبيحي ولواء ناصر منصور
هادي المشمولان بقرار مجلس الامن الدولي
وبحسب الفريق الحكومي المفاوض فان اليوم
الثاني يشمل تبادل دفعه اخرى من المحتجزين
عبر مطارات ابها وصنعاء والرياض والمخاه
اما اليوم الثالث فيشمل عمليه تبادل عبر
مطر صنعاء وتداوين بمحافظه مارب بينهم
اربعه الصحفيين محكومون عليهم بالاعدام
من جانبه رحب المبعوث الاموي الى اليمن
هاز جولدنبيرج ببدء صفقه تبادل الاسرى بين
اطراف النزاع في اليمن وقال في بيان ان
عمليه الافراج تاتي في وقت يسوده الامل في
اليمن كتذكير بان الحوار البناء والتسويه
المتبادله كلها ادوات قويه وقادره على
تحقيق نتائج مهمه هذا واضاف انه يامل ان
ينعكس او تنعكس هذه الروح في الجهود
الجاريه للدفع بحل سياسي شامل في اليمن
وحث الاطراف على الافراج الفوري وغير
المشروط عن جميع الافراد المحتجزين تعسفيا
وعلى الالتزام بالمعايير القانونيه
الدوليه فيما يتعلق بالاحتجاز وايضا
بالمحاكمه العادله
متابعه لتبادل المحتجزين معنا من مطار عدن
مراسل الجزيره ياسر حسن ياسر نتابع معك
مرصدته حتى الان عن انطلاق الطائرات من
مطار عدن وكذلك وصول طائرات من صنعاء الى
مطار عدن
نعم قبل قليل وصلت الطائره تتبع او تشريف
عليها
الصليب الاحمر الدولي وعلى متنها 35 على
متنها خمسه وثلاثون من
الاسرى التابعين للحكومه الشرعيه وعلى
راسهم وزير الدفاع الاسباق محمود الصبيحي
وكذلك ناصر منصور هادي شقيق الرئيس اليمني
السابق عبد ربه منصور هادي هذه هي الدفعه
الاولى التي تصل الى مطار عدن من قائمه من
صنعاء وهناك ايضا طائره اخرى ستصل هذا
اليوم تحمل ايضا على متنها 35
من الاسراء التابعين للحكومه الشرعيه
وكذلك ايضا قبل اكثر من ساعه من الان
انطلقت من مطار عدرا الدولي
طائره على متنها
125 من الاسرى الحوثيين انطلقت الى صنعاء
وربما قد وصلت الى ان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هي اكبر صفقه لتبادل الاسرى بين الحوثيين
من جهه
والحكومه الشرعيه والتحالف من جهه اخرى
شكرا لك من مطار عدن مراسل جزيره ياسر حسن